la dernière fois on a vu qu'il n'y avait
pas de bonnes raisons de penser que
l'intelligence humaine était spécifique
à l'espèce humaine et qu'en particulier
il n'était pas facile d'exclure
l'émergence d'une intelligence
artificielle qui possédait toutes les
facultés de l'intelligence humaine
mais une telle intelligence sera est
elle nécessairement intelligente
l'intelligence artificielle peut-elle
vraiment pensé banon et je ne parle pas
des ia d'aujourd'hui la question que je
pose c'est une ia sera t-elle un jour
capable d'avoir ses propres réflexions
est ce qu'il serait possible pugnace
face des maths comme moi mieux que moi
et d'ailleurs qu'est ce qui vous dit que
je ne suis pas une ia j'avoue qu'un truc
pré enregistré ça pourrait être une
machine qui te dis que je suis
préenregistré lee c'est le nom qu'on
donne oui alors comme ça il existe lis
tu doutes qu'unia peut penser bah je
pense que je pense qu'une ya peu faire
des trucs qui ressemble à de la
réflexion mais enfin ça reste une
machine
ok peut-être que la question une machine
peut-elle pensée est un petit peu trop
ambigu en sciences on préfère poser des
questions qu'on pourra tester avec des
expériences et c'est justement là
remarque café alan turing en 1950 plutôt
qu'à dresser un problème insoluble qui
éveille l'hooliganisme prowl manie sans
nous ou l'hooliganisme pro technologie
turing s'est demandé quelle expérience
scientifique s'en rapprocherait le plus
et c'est là qu'il a proposé le test de
turing
et si quoi ce test pour commencer il
faut définir un niveau d'intelligence
que la machine doit atteindre
j'imagine qu'on va considérer
l'intelligence humaine oui surtout qu'à
l'époque de turing les machines étaient
loin d'être intelligente
ok donc le test de turing consiste à
tester si une machine peut être au moins
aussi intelligente qu'un humain
exactement
et comment tester ça et bien en pratique
pour tester quelqu'un notamment avant de
l'embaucher une bonne chose à faire est
d'avoir un entretien avec lui
et du coup le test de turing va
consister à avoir un entretien avec ma
machine
en gros oui et à la fin de cet entretien
il faudra déterminer si la machine a
paru aussi intelligente qu'un humain sa
part est subjective tout coup oui du
coup turing propose un test d'un dicerna
bilité une machine aura passé le test de
turing s'il aura été impossible pour les
interrogateurs de déterminer s'il était
en train de s'entretenir avec une
machine ou avec un humain on parle d'un
vrai entretien autour d'une table je
suis désolé mais dans ce cas là il
paraît évident que la machine aura du
mal à camoufler ce qu'elle est vraiment
non bien sûr
surtout qu'à l'époque de turing ça
n'aurait pas été imaginable et puis
après tout l'apparence physique de la
machine ne devrait pas jouer
turing voulait un test d'intelligence du
coup il proposait un entretien par
message taper interposés bon que nous
jouerons peut faire cet entretien via un
chat
typiquement ok je vois du coup on prend
des interrogateurs et on les fait
s'entretenir avec des machines et on
voit quelle est la fraction des
interrogateurs qui pensaient
s'entretenir avec des machines
oui il faut aussi un groupe de contrôle
oui en laissant les interrogateurs
s'entretenir avec des humains et comme
ça on peut savoir quelle fraction du mal
à se faire passer pour des humains
exactement une machine aura passé le
test de turing si elle parvient à
paraître au moins aussi souvent humain
que les humains ni arrive alors petite
question avant d'aller plus loin je
parais bien
ah ça oui tu pars est bien humain yes
j'ai passé le test de turing est de
coutume on pense capable de penser
là je suis pas tout à fait convaincu
pour ce soit un test d'intelligence il
faudrait que l'intelligence soit
nécessaire pour passer les tests en a
fait mais si ça se trouve baath est
juste en train de lire un texte
j'avoue que c'est en gros ce que je fais
quand je tourne une vidéo mais du coup
au moment où tu me parles tu ne
réfléchis pas faisons un test de penser
imaginons tu dois passer le test de
turing dans le chinois du parc chinois
pour bon choix pour ton droit quoi ça
veut dire non je ne parle pas de chinois
ok imaginons que je t'envoie un message
écrit en chinois et imaginons tu
disposes d'un livre avec des phrases
classique en chinois et les réponses
classiques à ces phrases battue pourrait
retrouver le message que je t'ai envoyé
et écrire la réponse qui correspond oui
en effet bah alors tu aurais passé le
test de turing laissa sans avoir compris
le sens des messages échangés et donc
sans avoir réfléchi intéressant ce que
tu décris la l expérience de pensée de
la chambre chinoise opposé par le
philosophe john soeur soeur l'a imaginé
un individu enfermés dans une salle avec
un livre d'instruction qui fait
exactement ce que tu dis essabah ça
prouve qu'on peut passer 200 être
intelligent non c'est ce qu'affirme
jones heures
et prétend qu'une machine qui passerait
le test de turing aura un comportement
purement syntaxiques
c'est à dire qu'il ne fera en fait que
de la manipulation de symbole par
opposition un chinois qui au moment de
passer le test résoudrait avec la
sémantique c'est à dire le sens des mots
qui lui écrit une machine ferai ce que
tu es sans doute en train de faire elle
les noms seraient des phrases sans se
poser la question de son sens sauf que
l'expérience de pensée de john zorn
souffre d'une imitation pratique majeur
ah ouais et laquelle livre d'instruction
aura bien du mal à contenir toutes les
phrases imaginables d'un interrogateur
supposons que l'on construit une phrase
mot par mot et qu'à chaque instant il y
à peu près dix mots pour compléter la
phrase et supposons que les phrases de
l'interrogateur fonds typiquement 15 mo
alors ça nous fait dix mots possibles
pour le premier mot puis à nouveau dix
mots possibles pour le second mot puis à
nouveau 10 et ainsi de suite et ça au
total ça fait 10 puissance 15 phrase
possible soit un million de milliards
et ça c'est un très très grand nombre un
très gros livre contient environ 100000
phrase pour que la chambre chinoise de
jones earl contiennent toutes les
phrases possible il lui faudrait
contenir 10 milliards de gros livres
la chambre devrait en fait être un
immense entrepôt de quelques centaines
de mètres de long de large et de hauteur
ou enfin tout ça ça pourrait être
compressés dans des disques durs n'ont
certes mais maintenant le problème c'est
de trouver la phrase de l'interrogateur
dans les 10 milliards de livres d'accord
j'avoue là ça paraît tout de suite plus
compliqué mais il ya pire
les réponses qu'il faut donner un
certain l'instant dépendent de tout ce
qui a été dit avant et du coup si on
prend aussi c'est en compte on se rend
compte que la taille du fichier
informatique qui contient toutes les
réponses à toutes les suites de
questions imaginables d'un interrogateur
excéderait de loin tout le contenu
informatique du web
il faut alors nécessairement une
représentation beaucoup plus compressé
de tout cet ensemble de données hors
chercher une information dans cet
immense bordel compressé prendrait des
années y compris avec un ordinateur pour
répondre en temps réel
l'humain devra extraire l'information de
manière intelligente
c'est alors cette extraction de
l'information qui serait intelligente
ok mais imaginons donc le travail de
recherche soit entièrement automatisés
si bien qu'au final un programme te dise
exactement ce que tu dois écrire pour
paraître intelligent hockey dans ce cas
là tu aurais passé le test sans
réfléchir
oui mais dans ce cas je n'aurais pas
passé le test seuls ceux qui aura
vraiment passé le test
c'est l'ensemble mois + machine est
d'ailleurs en l'occurrence ce sera
surtout la machine ok je vois là où tu
veux en venir
toi tu aurait été bête mais pas la
machine exactement et ctu débarrasser de
la machine
en faisant ce qu'elle fait qu'est ce que
tu vas dire bah la machine ne fait que
suivre des instructions un programme un
code informatique
du coup ce que tu pourrais faire c'est
apprendre par coeur ses instructions et
ensuite les appliquer mécaniquement en
effet mais alors tu aurais passé le test
de turing en me faisant qui effectue et
bêtement des opérations syntaxique tu
pourrais communiqué en chinois sans rien
comprendre aux chinois et tu aurais
passé le test de turing sans avoir
vraiment réfléchi en effet et donc on
est d'accord
un simple jeu de symboles suffit à
résoudre le test de turing
oui on est d'accord donc turing avait
tort et le test de turing n'est pas un
des intelligences mais est ce vraiment
la conclusion de cette expérience de
pensée ce qu'on a vraiment conclut c'est
que la manipulation de symboles suffit à
passer le test de turing
mais ça ça n'a rien d'étonnant après
tout comme on le verra dans le prochain
épisode
une machine ne fait que de la
manipulation de symbole est ce que tu a
résolu le test du tuning sans
intelligence et sans compréhension
sémantique on est tué sur la
mémorisation du programme de conduite
elle pas justement à l'apprentissage du
sens du chinois et appliquer les règles
du programme ne conduit-il pas
finalement à manipuler la sémantique du
chinois
ouais tu as raison il paraît difficile
de mémoriser tout cela sans en ressortir
une certaine compréhension le noeud du
problème c'est que le programme
nécessaire pour passer le test de turing
est un programme si complexe qu après 67
ans de recherches dans le domaine
personne n'a su l'écrire et clairement
du coup personne n'assume mémoriser et
en particulier à prendre ce programme a
de bonnes chances d'être bien plus
instructif que tous les livres de cours
de chinois écrit dans l'histoire de
l'humanité
passé le test de turing semble
nécessairement requérir une certaine
forme de compréhension sémantique du
langage et c'est pour ça que le test de
turing est vraiment un test considéré
très important et qu'il est devenu un
les marques de l'intelligence
artificielle
introduit en 1950 il a influencé de
nombreux psychologues philosophes et
informaticiens et il semblerait que
l'intelligence ou une condition vraiment
nécessaire pour le passé est d'ailleurs
malgré quelques annonces à gauche et à
droite je pense qu'on peut vraiment
considérer que le test de turing est
encore loin d'avoir été passé on peut
même imaginer que seuls unis à forte
pourra vraiment passé le test de turing
est parti à forte
j'entends une ia qui surpasse l'humain
dans tous les domaines est vraiment le
génie de tueries c'est d'avoir anticipé
tout cela dès 1950 ou delà du défi
technologique ce qui est fascinant avec
le test de turing c'est ce qu'il nous
dit sur la façon dont on réfléchit sur
l'étonnante complexité de notre façon de
réfléchir et d'interagir après tout
notre cerveau n'est qu'un ensemble de
neurones qui effectue un traitement
syntaxique de signaux électriques
cependant la sémantique semble émerger
de cette combinaison d'opérations
syntaxiques
mais pour bien comprendre tout cela il
va nous falloir parler des concepts
fondamentaux de l'informatique et en
particulier de la plus grande invention
de turing à savoir la machine des
tueries allez j'espère que vous avez
aimé cet épisode
un énorme merci à licques syphilis de la
chaîne macroscopique que je vous invite
à aller les voir
qui parle de pas mal de trucs notamment
en psychologie et trucs très intéressant
notamment le syndrome de l'imposteur ou
encore la ludification pour permettre
l'apprentissage
donc allez-y abonnez-vous à sa chaîne
c'est vraiment cool d'aller enfin on a
rejeté cinq arguments selon lesquels
l'intelligence humaine serait une
spécificité humaine et dans la vidéo est
intervenu thibault de la chaîne monsieur
fils voulait un peu que ça soit une
surprise pour ça que les commissions
dans le titre par contre tu oublié de
présenter sa chaîne en fin de vidéo ça
c'est peut-être parce que j'arrive pas
de présenter sa chaîne j'ai l'impression
moi j'adore ce qui fait et si vous ne
connaissez tour patty beauchamp
mais pas des vrais fans de seine
notamment dans les liens de la vidéo
précédente
il ya énormément de liens vers ses
vidéos et qui nous fait la remarque que
de nombreux experts du machine learning
et de l'intelligence artificielle
affirme régulièrement qu'aujourd'hui
l'intelligence artificielle n'est
vraiment pas prêtes de réussir
l'intelligence artificielle forte une
intelligence général est en effet
aujourd'hui il faut bien s'en rend
compte que les machines même si elle y
arrive à faire beaucoup de choses qu'on
sait pas faire ou des choses qu'on croit
savoir faire et qu'elles le font
beaucoup mieux que nous en fait les
machines d'aujourd'hui sont pas encore
vraiment intelligente en tout cas elles
sont pas capables de passer le test de
turing
et c'est pas forcément vendeur que de
dire ça de ma série mais en gros ce dont
on va parler eux dans cette série
notamment le dip leur nid je pense
personnellement que ce n'est pas la
solution tout cas c'est pas la solution
finale pour pouvoir avoir une
intelligence artificielle forte
cependant la recherche dans le domaine
continue à avancer un rythme incroyable
et a beaucoup de découvertes récentes
qui tendent à montrer que en fait il ya
encore beaucoup beaucoup de progrès en
tant d'un point de vue théorique à faire
dans le domaine notamment ceux qui
écoutent le podcast axium que je tiens
justement avec thibault eh bien vous
savez peut-être que moi je pense
personnellement que la bonne solution
c'est passer par un truc qui s'appelle
le pays via nice mme ceci dit cette
petite convictions personnelles qu en
fait une énorme mixte personnel ça reste
une conviction uniquement personnel j'en
veux dire et qui ne fait absolument pas
consensus ou en tout cas pas entièrement
consensus aujourd'hui même si j'ai
l'impression que le baiser nice ne gagne
de plus en plus notamment dans le monde
de la recherche en intelligence
artificielle
kevin tega fait justement la remarque
qu'aujourd'hui les machines ont beaucoup
de mal à apprendre en fait leur faut
énormément d'exemple souvent des
milliers voire des dizaines de milliers
voire des millions d'exemplaires pouvoir
apprendre un truc comme qu'est ce qu'un
chat alors qu'un humain arrive à prendre
ça très très rapidement notamment les
bébés c'est quelque chose dont on a
parlé attendant dans le podcast action
du coup je ne peux pas résister à
l'envié de vous passer un petit passage
maintenant j'ai entraînement filer les
cours du collège de france de stanislas
de haine parce qu'il ya notamment un
cours qui la donne et qui s'appelle le
cerveau statisticiens la révolution
bayésienne en neurosciences chez sogeti
et c'est vraiment passionnant et je
pense qu'il ya beaucoup à apprendre
d'eux des sciences cognitives
ce qui a beaucoup de progrès qui ont été
faits récemment et terme en 2011 et un
mec s'appelle tenenbaum qui a publié un
article où il présente trois images d'un
truc qu'il appelle tu fais ça veut rien
dire les images représentent rien de
réel il dit bon bah ça c'est un tu face
à saintes uva et ça c'est un tu fasses
ensuite il montre 39 image et il nous
demande de trouver les tue fort et tu
vas sont pas les mêmes c'est des objets
c'est comme des animaux que des plantes
est ce qu'il faut c'est que on est tous
d'accord
ah ouais on est tous d'accord c'est ce
qu'il appelle le scandale de l'induction
c'est qu'avec trois exemples uniquement
positif il te dit pas ce que n'est pas
un tu vois tes dis juste ce qu'est un tu
vas te juste trois exemples de tuffeau
et on arrive tous à se mettre d'accord
sur en gros ce qu'est un tu fais ça
c'est génial
j'aime bien les voir les tuche mais sam
et impactant que ça quelque part ça que
c'est étonnant mais je veux dire
oui on a l'impression qu'il ya quelque
chose de très solides dans la façon dont
une zone de l'induction
c'est un argument qui revient assez
souvent l'idée qu' il centre dans la
détermination de la référence à un thème
assez classe et en philosophie l'idée
s'éviter un chien quand parle dit par
exemple si je dis ceci est off on compte
quelque chose il ya un milliard de façon
genre en montrant un crayon il ya un
milliard de façon d'interpréter cette
définition est en fait ce que nous
aurons d'exemple c'est que c'est pas si
vrai apparemment en tout cas que de fait
même s'il ya théoriquement un milliard
de façon d'interpréter quelque chose
comme ceci étant tu fais quand on montre
juste quelques exemples vraiment pas
nombreux mais en fait il semble que on
arrive tous à se mettre d'accord sur la
façon correcte d'interpréter cette
définition sensive donc tu es toute la
recherche en sciences cognitives
tellement la recherche bayésienne en
sciences cognitives qui cherchent à
comprendre comment on est capable de
généraliser le tuf à partir de trois
exemples est une hypothèse très très
simple en fait qui est une structure une
structuration de l'ensemble des objets
sous forme d'un arbre qui ressemble
beaucoup à l'arbre du vivant la vie de
génétique du vivant et du coup quand on
prend trois exemples comme ça donc vous
imaginez que ces trois branches grâce
comme trois espèces animales et bien le
ce qu'on va considérer comme étant un tu
fasses ça va être l'intersection
la partie de l'arbre qui plus est la
plus petite partie de l'arbre qui
correspond à ces trois exemples
oui je vois l'idée mes objections à ce
qu'on pourrait dire il ya toutes sortes
de façons de dessiner cet arbre c'est
qu'on me dessine tous de la même façon
bah là encore il ya les principes
béliziens qui hors là c'est vraiment
vraiment impressionnant le court
mâcher le travail je sais lire comme les
extrémistes et j'ai vu le court j'ai
fait mais c'est pas possible
adjibi croyez pas que il ya des
principes plaisir de partout et ça
marche super bien et donc en fait il ya
un principe parisien qui permettent non
seulement de construire l'arbre
il ya même un autre principe balayant le
belize hiérarchique est capable de
choisir l'arbre comme structure de
données parmi d'autres structures de
donner deux représentations de modèles
possibles
il ya pas mal de modèles qui marchent
très bien en machine learning en gros
notre cerveau notamment bébé est capable
et 20 à quelque part dans sa tête
toutes ses formes de modèle est juste en
impliquant ensuite la forme de bisons
des approximations en forte baisse
il arrive à sélectionner les modèles qui
marchent bien pour apprendre à parler ou
pour reconnaître des tuffes c'est
vraiment impressionnant
or ces normes parce que ça voudrait dire
que ça rend juste notre nos cerveaux
livrant bien vieillir c'est juste une
rationalité qui ne l'est pas fondées
système rationnel mal à appliquer la
formule de bayes consciemment mais
inconsciemment la piscine sens c'est ça
l'idée ces envois ont été sélectionnés
protection naturelle pour être capables
de faire ce genre d'inférence bayésienne
inconsciente très rapidement sans qu'on
puisse comprendre comment ça fonctionne
parce que c'est très automatique
mais dès qu'on commence à raisonner sur
des concepts abstraits on n'a pas été
sélectionné pour capacité à raisonner
sur une flaque abstrait ben là on
commence à avoir beaucoup de mal
calculer les probabilités cunico rentrer
le plus grand quotidien m enfin lionel
duval nous demande aussi une dictature
par les ja ne serait pas la solution à
la politique bon peut-être pas les ja
d'aujourd'hui est encore beaucoup de
progrès à faire mais j'ai surtout envie
de dire qu'en fait les ja prennent de
plus en plus de décisions
je pense que quand on parle de pouvoir
de structures sociales on pense beaucoup
à ceux qui ont sauvé de la politique au
président au ministre mais des décisions
collectives qui vont certes beaucoup de
gens à la fois et qui structurent
vraiment nos sociétés il y en a en fait
énormément à plein des champs dans la
société y compris ceux qui décident de
la norme 4g et 5g ou un truc du genre
tout ça ce sont des décisions
incroyablement impactante peut-être bien
plus que beaucoup des décisions dont on
parle beaucoup à la télé et dans ce
domaine les machines prennent de plus en
plus de décisions pour nous donc en fait
on est déjà petit à petit vers une épice
stockera si de plus en plus dirigé par
les machines
et c'est pas forcément une ovation à
dire tous les problèmes administratifs
s'il pouvait être réglé plus facilement
je lui dis pas non j'espère que vous
avez aimé cet épisode et que vous allez
vous demander mais qu'est ce que la
sémantique au final quelle est la
meilleure façon de définir vraiment ce
qu'est à sémantique c'est pas facile si
vous avez fléchissez et
et peut-être qu'on ait fait ça peut
émerger de quelque chose de purement
mécanique et peut-être même que tout
l'univers émergent de quelque chose qui
est en fait purement mécanique les
clauses qui est purement une machine
peut-être univers est une énorme machine
c'est ce dont on va longuement parlé
l'apf une fois puisqu'on va aborder la
machine de turing emma lois de la
physique préféré même si les physiciens
la connaissent peut-être un pas à savoir
la thèse de church curie si vous avez
aimé cet épisode penser à le l'ikea le
commentaire de partage et pensez à vous
abonner pour ne pas manquer futurs
épisodes merci aux tee-shirts polos
redon et j'espère que vous serez là la
prochaine fois
[Musique]
ap